[Music]
all right let's go out to Indiana and
talk to the Sarah with an H what's up
Sarah that's the only way to spell it I
can't comment what's
up oh I am just enjoying this beautiful
sunny day
fantastic yes how are you I am enjoying
a beautiful sunny day too except I'm
locked in this studio here what's up
true okay so I am looking for some help
with the situation with my youngest
daughter I am wondering who can help me
advocate for her um she is having to
share a bedroom with her almost
11-year-old stepbrother at her dad's
house nope out out out out out out out
out out out out well I agree with you um
let but let me tell you this so simply
asking her dad to make a change in room
Arrangements which is where I started it
hasn't worked um and with other things
that have come up um it it seems that
he that makes him dig his heels in even
deeper in resistance because I asked
call your attorney call your attorney
today well let me let me I'm getting all
fired up about it all right I'll be
quiet I'll be fired up too um so like
having you know when her
dad so let me tell you another can I
just tell you another story another
situation sure okay so um I have three
kids they're now 16 almost 14 and almost
nine and when the
16-year-old was 14 I found out out that
um my ex-husband was letting him drive
his Toyota 4Runner around public roads
like not down back Country Roads not you
know in parking lots like to and from
church to and from the grocery store and
I called my attorney at that because I
pick my battles you know and that to me
was
red waving
flag and I really felt like the legal
system failed me it just it just didn't
go
anywhere and so this is why I'm asking
you for help and I hear you say call my
attorney but my experience when things
have happened and there's another kind
of other thing Brewing too I have asked
him to um not allow our almost
14-year-old they the girls both turn um
a year older in February so they're very
close but
she he owns a golf cart and he allows
her to drive it around and she drives it
onto a busy road that goes between
neighborhoods I have jumped up and down
no no no and I have told her no no no I
don't get anywhere with him um so I feel
I feel very
powerless when you called your attorney
did you call your attorney as though you
were calling the police or did you call
to alter the um custody
arrangement
um the attorney that I I used a
different attorney at that time than I
did with my divorce okay um and she kind
of treated it
like
we we can't do anything because it's
after the
fact that's
completely all right here's what I know
I know I have not I'm to be honest I
haven't read the data recently okay it's
been a couple of years but I know that a
significant amount of abuse comes from
stepparents stepf
fathers and um that extended additional
Circle right that non-blood
Circle I do understand the tragedy that
is letting a kid drive a
car probably what I would do in the
future is call the police and tell them
there's a 14-year-old driving a vehicle
right now and have the kid arrested and
then it would go back to
Dad but I tell you all that to tell you
because I'd much rather my kid get
arrested and by the way they're not
going to get in trouble or 14 the adult
is the one who put them in the car um
I'd much rather rather my kid get
arrested than get
hit right yeah but all that to
say you have new information that your
kids may not be
safe in those three instances it is
completely inappropriate for an
8-year-old girl to share a room with an
11-year-old non-biological sibling
period period period period you're not
crazy
okay you're not
crazy I know it's never okay to let
children drive
vehicles
right now like the golf cart thing in
these little golf cart neighborhoods
that are popping up all over the place
that's a different conversation I
I we'll just have that conversation
later let's just talk about the original
one that you're like what you're telling
me is the courts looked at the facts
gave dad custody Arrangement a and gave
you custody Arrangement B you all signed
it and you left or the judge ruled on it
and you left now you have new
information yeah I mean the the
landscape in our lives is totally
different I mean we've been um I mean I
we separated almost five years
ago next month I you know I moved out I
bought a house um we've been formally
divorced for four years at that time
excuse me at that time there wasn't
anyone else in the picture um he pretty
quickly got
remarried and um and brought and and she
brought three kids into the picture so
you know
there's six kids and two adults and you
know I I respect try to be respectful of
my children when they're here I don't
nitpick them for information but when
they talk to me about it I listen very
open you know open ears um I think the
thing with my daughter
um this the rooming nonbiologically
related children and especially of
different genders that bothered me just
if you put it down on paper it's like no
but she also she came
into um when they all were at my house
she came
into the my son's room we were all
hanging out in there and she just had
was ready for bed she had on one of my
t-shirts just long t-shirt and then she
came back in there and she had she had
the shirt off and she was just wearing
her underwear and I was like what that
up and she said something like well if
boys can do it girls can do it too and I
was just like my mom's Spidey senses
just kind of went off and I thought
that's different that's weird that's
kind of not sitting right with me and
and I just got the feeling of maybe
because she's sharing a room with a
young boy and not to say that I I don't
think and when I've asked her she
doesn't say
that anything is going on and I don't
name him specifically and they have gone
over Safe Touch curriculum they actually
are talking about that in her school but
I'm also just not a dummy all right
Sarah listen listen to me okay yeah I'm
just telling you this from a parent of
an eight-year-old
girl
no right and here's how I would handle
this if I were you you've been burned by
the system before okay or you you you
feel burned I don't know if that system
actually didn't actually quote unquote
failed you but you made a call one time
no one did anything they said hey it's
too late that is what it is
fine here's how I would proceed and you
have to understand that when it comes to
the health and safety of my daughter I
will burn it all down yeah okay that's
number one number two if I've learned
anything after talking with countless
young women I can't even count the
number of women who sat in my office
over two decades and told me things that
happened to them as kids It's
haunting okay yeah trust
every I would much rather you trust your
gut and be
wrong than trust your gut I mean than
have this feeling that you know
something's not right and you're like ah
well you know so here's how I would
handle it I would tell my ex I need you
to know I'm going to call everybody on
planet Earth everybody
CPS Child Protective Services an
attorney to try to get new custody
Arrangements I'm going to call the
police I'm going to call the school
counselor I'm calling
everybody I'm also taking our daughter
to a a child counselor hopefully she's
seeing somebody anyway about the
integration with a different family and
you're going to ask for a forensic
interview tell her I found out she is
sharing a room with an 11-year-old boy
that's a stepbrother and and suddenly
things have just changed with
her okay
yeah
also I would contact the school and ask
them to keep their eyes
open okay yep now let me ask you this
this is a very personal question have
you experienced this before when you
were a
kid
um yes and no and let me just put it
this way I did not experience um sexual
abuse as a child when I was um similar
ages my my brother and I were Um how my
grandparents were visiting and you know
so we got kicked out it was like a
family event whatever we got kicked out
of our rooms and so we were bunked up in
a bed one occasion and it was kind of
like what happens if we touch parts so I
so it it's bothered me he and I talked
about it and we both had that guilt and
shame from that experience but I did not
repeat you know have any sort of
repeated
sexual abuse or trauma how old was
he he was 11 how old were you
seven but I came to find out after that
that he um younger than that when we
lived in a different
place that he had been a victim of um
from Neighbors that he had been
sodomized and and you know raped by kids
in the neighborhood and he had been
through a lot of trauma that he still it
it's something he has a lot of struggle
with today but sarah sarah sarah he's
not on the phone with me today you are
no he's not
yeah what happened to you was
wrong for sure
no what happened to you is wrong oh and
I've and my ex my
ex-husband
um he he did
let me let me you don't have to go into
it all you know what I'm talking about
right no I do and okay hold on hold on
hold hold hold on you know okay so
listen
listen the alarms going off inside of
you please please listen to them
okay they are I'm I
am I also am just
afraid of not for not because I don't
want to protect my kids but there's a
part of me that is just afraid of taking
on that battle with
him be because of
the emotional abuse and all that went on
in our marriage Sarah if you don't stand
up for your daughter who's going to
stand up for her I know I
know what happened to you was wrong what
your husband did to you your ex-husband
did to you was evil and
[Music]
wrong and if you notice I didn't tell
you to take him on all by yourself I
told you to kindly let him know I
wouldn't say kindly to let him know
you're bringing in everybody you
can and I'm willing to accept any
nonsense you want to throw my way
because what happened to me is not going
to happen to my daughter
true and maybe your alarms are are more
sensitive than others because of what
you've experience great I'm still going
to listen to them
anyway yeah I grew up in Houston where
there were hurricanes all the time and
I'm the weekend after a bunch of
tornadoes that just came through town
here in Nashville when the sirens go off
I
overreact because I've been there sure
yeah right I've been there right
and a lot of people lost everything this
past
weekend right yeah and so it's not that
my alarms were wrong they just were off
this time
fine but I would contact a therapist I
would contact the school I would let him
know if this boy isn't out of that if
they're not in different Arrangements by
the end of today you're going to call
child protective services and let them
know exactly what you've um went through
what what your daughter has
said and will it cause a stir ABS
freaking
lutely will your daughter at eight years
old maybe say Mom I had to go meet with
so and so and this maybe will your
ex-husband talk crap about you to your
daughter and she's going to repeat some
of it to you maybe probably not but
maybe well I think that already happens
it does it does it does but I want you
to ask the question if you don't stand
up for her who
will
yeah who
okay yeah will you call a counselor by
the end of today and set up an
appointment for you and your daughter
yeah sure I mean we already I have
established
um myself and my other daughter already
at a place so I can do that that is easy
I want you to call and ask for a
forensic interview because you think
something may have
happened okay and you can tell them I
have my own childhood experiences with
this I may be overreacting but this
stuff happened and every bit of every
alarm I have went off okay and I want
you
to it's not it's I wouldn't run from
it for the sake of my eight-year-old
daughter I'll burn it all
down and by the way if you're my friend
and I think think something's going
wrong and I ask you about it directly I
challenge you on it
directly my goodness I hope you would be
like man absolutely I'm glad you were
you were standing up for that 8-year-old
girl it didn't happen but man good for
you I remember a great story where a kid
a dad was carrying a kid into a store
and the kid was kicking and screaming
and kicking and screaming and somebody
walking out of the store stopped them
and talked to the
kid and it ended up being that it was
just a kid throwing a temper tantrum
with the dad taking her into a store but
the Dad instead of getting mad and
indignant asked the stranger or told the
stranger hey thank you for getting
involved because if somebody ever
happens to be taking my daughter into a
store trying to kidnap her run away with
her I hope somebody will intervene like
you did thank
you and if your ex-husband is such an
utter
scumbag that he'd rather bury his head
in the sand or rather punish
you by sticking her in that room and not
picking up on the signs when she starts
walking around with different clothes on
start saying things that are very un
eight-year-old or maybe that's an
eight-year-old statement but it should
be
challenged man
I'm sorry Sarah
sorry call
everybody